Does the new bulb have different frequency and we have to replace what we have now with the new one?
Don't hey, oh
Okay, please you're not saying you need to replace anything. So the new bulb does not have different frequency
It has it just is has contains more gas
So all your bulbs with a plasma bulb or a Tesla bulb is it contains a gas
And then you have running electrical frequencies through the gas and now you're getting those frequencies through the light
That is produced by that gas
If you have more gas you have the potential of getting a greater
quantity of frequencies, therefore
Possibly a better treatment from the same
application, so
Um a larger bulb has greater benefits that way
so
You've asked people have asked me over the years should I get this bulb or that bulb or that was true right this even with michael
The company of course they make money selling bulbs they make money their equipment company they make money selling stuff
And I've said you can buy as many bulbs you want but
But in most part you really only need the hammer bulb. You're using it at night
The other bulbs are breakable
Can't really use it at night and you know unless you're running a lot of day programs
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense to have these other bulbs
Well a true rife was bought out they made their their hammer bulb shrink
So the new hammer bulbs are you know
probably
Or 60 inches smaller and I wasn't you know happy with that
Um, but you know short of developing our own bulb
Um, we we could really do about it
Um, so we developed our own bulb so
We're gonna be selling our gonna be larger. We don't have them yet
You also can't buy one yet. We don't have them all this store
Hope to have them, you know, you know, Ronald takes giving time
Was the proposed
speculation and then it really I'm giving credit where credits do it's
I'm trying to buy Gary young and to do most of work on develop really all the work on developing this bulb so
um
But uh, we've been teaming up with ideas
So try to just provide the best for everybody
And uh, well that's what our purpose is. So